- Shaun told me to go out there.
I'm a little intimidated
and there's people in suits.
I'm gonna do it.
He said to refer to him as his driver
and not his Uber driver.
He said to keep it brand ambiguous.
I don't know what that means.
But he's making me go out there now
and he's being really mean again.
(loud chatting)
Shonduras just called us up and asked us
to come by to be in a
drift cart tournament
that he's having this afternoon.
But the thing is, whoever loses first,
has to be the winner's Uber driver
for the rest of the day.
Which means that you have to go anywhere
the winner wants to go.
I'm tangled up...
- What's up, guys?
- Yeah what's up, man?
- Dude, good to see ya.
- What's up?
- Good to see ya.
- We're a little early.
- You're all good.
Hey man.
- [Carmichael] What's up?
- That's our secret
best friends handshake.
We've had it for years.
- We're here with Shonduras
and Dan from What's Inside?
- 'Sup?
- We're gonna do Capture the Cone.
The rules of Capture the Cone
are magnificently simple.
You see this beautiful,
magnificent cone right here?
All you have to do is capture
it from the other player.
("Hit That Super Mario" by DJ Flex)
- You know Shaun called
me up about two hours ago
and said, "Do you wanna
come over and hang out?"
And I said, "Sure."
I've never drift carted before
but I've played a lot of Mario Kart,
I thought I'd be fine.
- He's an incredible driver.
- Three!
Two!
One!
Fight!
(go-karts revving)
- Good drift!
- [Jake] I put my heart out there.
I think I put everything
out on the course.
I've got no question that
I've got all the confidence
in the world in my trainers.
- [Shonduras] Good show, good show, oh!
(intense music)
- Oh, butterfingers!
I was a little nervous.
But that first time when I did my move
where I looked like I was goin' right
and then I spun around, I knew I had him.
(tires screeching)
Whoa!
(muffled shouting)
(everyone shouting)
Yeah you know,
you can't plan these things.
I hate driving.
- [Shonduras] I hope you
have the worst day ever.
(go-karts revving)
- Woo! (shouting)
I'm the best.
Ooh!
- I haven't felt that since high school;
back when we'd be drifting
out in the back alleys.
Just those were asphalt days.
No rules, no regulations, just
drifting for the heck of it.
And when I looked at him in the eyes,
it brought me back to those days.
This was not, I do not feel like this
was a professional drifting,
this was just back to the days when it was
in back alleys, you know what I mean?
Psychological battle, oh!
- [Group] Oh!
- Rip it, turn it, that's
kinda been my motto.
I've got one of them drift
or die tattoos right here
and you know, this is
just the cart's part of me
more than I'm part of the cart.
- Nothing can go wrong.
Get it on!
Oh!
- Oh!
And I just think he didn't come prepared.
He was thinking a little
too much about YouTube,
not enough about drifting,
you know what I mean?
(door slams)
- (beeps)
- Dang unfortunate that
neither Carmichael or I
made it into the final round.
But nonetheless...
- Thanks for making
this video for us guys.
Let us know when it's on
your channel. (laughs)
- Thanks guys.
- Nonetheless, we're good sports.
That's how we do it over
here at Corridor Digital.
This is the championship round.
We've got Dan from What's Inside?
versus Shaun from Shonduras.
Who's gonna win, I don't know.
Capture the cone championship.
Shaun, are you ready?
Dan, are you ready?
Let's get it on!
Woo hoo!
(intense music)
- Dan from What's
Inside?, was a little bit
intimidating in that his YouTube
channel's pretty fanciful.
I looked at it last
night, kinda get to know
you opponent a little bit.
He's been cutting stuff open, but I think
that's kinda been
hindering him from training
because of uploading all
them videos to the internet.
Whoa, whoa!
See ya!
- Ahhhh!
- (shouting)
Subscribe to my channel!
- Shaun's a good friend and
I thought that I had him.
- I think I'm slowly getting an accent
throughout this interview.
It's getting more and more thick as we go.
I think that's just my
confidence coming out.
- I feel like I let everybody down.
I had it, the only reason why I lost
is because right here.
Any more questions?
- It would have been nice to see someone
out there representing us.
But, you know, when you go up against
other YouTubers, that's just the way
the cookie crumbles.
I know that on the next one...
- Did all the contestants have fun?
Look forward to seeing the guys next year,
especially that Carmichael,
he had some fire to him.
I hope he stays drifting.
- [Carmichael] Okay, so.
- We rolling?
- [Carmichael] Yeah.
- Alright so, here's the deal.
I really thought these guys were nice but
then they just put me in the car
and they kinda took it over
and they made me their Uber driver,
and then they brought me
- Best Uber driver
- to this super cold place.
- ever.
They brought me bag up the parts
and it's even colder up here.
And I'm really cold and
I don't have any food
and I have to pee.
Apparently they're taking us to some party
where there's like a booth and they said
it's going to be really fun, but honestly,
I'm a little scared because I heard that
there's human trafficking.
- Literally, who invited the Uber driver?
- I think I just saw,
what's the guys name that directed X-Men?
Bryan, I think I just saw Bryan Singer
and he looked at me funny.
What's the street address
where we're going?
- [Carmichael] 545.
- Yeah dude, you should know this,
like, you drive Uber all day.
- They brought me to a candy shop,
they bought me candy.
I mean overall I'm actually,
I'm still...
- (mumbles) Uber driver here.
This is my Uber driver, (mumbles)
- Hey, how's it going?
- [Cashier] No way!
- Do you want a caramel
apple or something, bud?
- I would love a caramel apple.
- See how they're just cut so you just
pull one of those off?
- Yeah.
- And then you just pop that, yeah.
- Pop it and eat it?
- Yep, just like this.
- Oh, thank you.
- And then, here let me.
Yeah, buddy, see that's good, right?
- I'm gonna get a great tip.
- Except, that's what the apple is.
- This caramel apple's really good.
And my wife, she makes me feel
like a three star but,
this guy, he's making me feel like a five.
We found a secret door so
we're inside now.
It's warm, so that's good.
He gave me a glass of bourbon.
- Forget this shoeless party,
I'm putting my shoes on,
I'm a rebel.
- Shaun said to put my shoes on.
Shaun told me to go out there,
I'm a little intimidated, to be honest.
There's just a lot of people
in suits that I don't know.
I've learned a lot.
I think I'm gonna start applying it.
(loud talking in background)
- I know which one this
is, they're all black
and they're all from the same company.
That wasn't a racist comment, by the way.
- (mumbles)
I mean when people call
me, and I don't know what
to do with them, I just start driving.
- Right, when people
call me and I don't know
what to do with them, I
just keep them entertained.
- That's kinda the same thing.
- Thanks, man.
Let's go out there and have this fun.
- Okay.
- Uber driver.
- Are you serious?
Hey man.
- It's our Uber driver.
- Uber driver's here for the party.
- If you think about
it, with me just being
with you guys makes me
feel a little bit better.
(mumbles) just being here by myself.
- It's good to have you, man.
Like, go mingle, meet some people.
- Yeah.
- You're with Shonduras,
dude, tonight's the night.
- Let's do it.
- He said not to drink too
much because if I do that
I won't be able to be his driver anymore.
("Sandstone" by Ginger Runner)
- Oh, but you were the Uber driver, right?
- How did you know that?
- We were in the same Uber together.
- You never get my Uber
drivers networking for me?
- You sent me to network for you?
- Oh yeah, keep networking.
Well, yeah.
- I've made a lot of contacts.
I met Matt Syler.
- Okay, um, he seemed like
a really nice guy actually.
- That's not water.
- You said I could have the best day ever.
- Thank you so much for letting us
battle it out
- Handclaps.
- on these sweet drift carts.
If you want to see rocket league drift,
go over to Space Station Crew Stuff video.
Maybe if you comment enough
on What's Inside? videos,
they'll cut one of those open.
- [Dan] That'd be fun.
- I'm down, I'm down.
- That'd be great.
- See you there, leave me a high five.
- That was fun.
(talking in background)
("Hit That Super Mario" by DJ Flex)
(yelling)